bonjour bienvenue à tous dans cette
édition 2015 d'Europe Hebdo nous sommes
à Strasbourg au Parlement européen dans
cette émission je vous emmène en
Allemagne un pays que l'on loue pour son
modèle économique mais un modèle
économique en trompe l'oeil nous en
débattrons à la fin de cette émission
mais d'abord l'actualité je suis Charlie
nous sommes Charlie depuis les attentats
survenus en France la semaine dernière
l'Europe le monde entier s'est retrouvé
à Paris capitale du monde d'après les
mots de François Hollande mais après
l'émotion que faire c'est la question de
la semaine et à les poser par Simon
barbarie
une image historique plus de 50
dirigeants du monde entier défilent à
Paris contre le terrorisme un symbole
sans précédent pour des crimes sans
précédent les attentats de Charlie Hebdo
de Montrouge et de la Porte de Vincennes
17 morts et 4 millions de personnes
déversées dans les villes françaises des
manifestations aussi à Londres Berlin
Rome Moscou New York ce lundi s'est
enfin autour du Parlement européen de
fer silence une Europe unie face à la
terreur
mais après l'émotion quelle solution
quelques jours après le drame déjà les
premières questions et les premières
polémiques et dont la ligne de Myr les
étrangers stop à l'immigration en Europe
pour Victor Orban Premier ministre
hongrois stop aux multiculturalisme pour
najol fairage leader du parti
britannique anti-européen yukip autre
débat celui de la réponse législative au
terrorisme et des libertés individuelles
les ministres de l'Intérieur européen
annoncent vouloir renforcer les
contrôles aux frontières extérieures de
l'Union et souhaite retirer les contenus
incitant à la haine et à la terreur sur
Internet
Premier ministre espagnol va même plus
loin et appelle à réformer l'espace
Schengen pour plus de contrôle alors
bientôt un patriote acte européen
et pour répondre à cette question c'est
Viviane Redding que je reçois bonjour
madame reading bonjour vous êtes député
européenne luxembourgeoise membre du
groupe PPE Parti populaire européen vous
êtes surtout vice ancienne
vice-présidente de la Commission
européenne quand vous voyez ces images
d'une Europe réunie derrière le
président François Hollande à Paris
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire mais ça me
fait chaud au cœur parce que l'Europe
c'est justement ça c'est la solidarité
c'est le travail ensemble tout en
restant soi-même notre plus grande
richesse c'est la diversité culturelle
chacun a des racines différentes et
ensemble nous faisons un tout et c'est
ça la force la beauté c'est l'union dans
la diversité finalement vous me disiez
avant de commencer cette émission qu'il
y avait même eu des rassemblements à
Luxembourg ah oui à Luxembourg dimanche
dernier les drapeaux étaient en berne et
il y a eu un rassemblement spontané
autour de la grande échelle du
Luxembourg qui a représenté la maison
royale et il y avait là des Français des
Luxembourgeois des gens d'autres
nationalités tous ensemble on a très peu
parlé mais on s'est tenu la main on a
chanté la Marseillaise on a chanté
l'hymne national luxembourgeois et on a
chanté
l'hymne européen et c'était plein plein
d'émotions c'était tout simplement un
groupe social
de cet endroit là qui dans l'adversité
se serrer les coudes et c'était très
émouvant alors justement derrière cette
union aujourd'hui il commence à pointer
quelques polémiques on recherche un
petit peu des responsabilités on voyait
dans le reportage de Simon barbarie que
Victor Orban heidel Farage avait
commencé à pointer la question du
communautarisme des étrangers d'un
manque d'intégration qu'est-ce que vous
avez à leur répondre j'ai alors répondre
que cet exemple du rassemblement
luxembourgeois c'est ça notre Europe ce
sont des gens de d'horizon différents de
culture différentes de religions
différentes qui se donnent la main parce
qu'ils veulent vivre ensemble et la
beauté de l'Europe c'est justement la
diversité dans l'unité eux ils ne
veulent pas de diversité ils ne veulent
pas mon Europe et bien je suis fier de
pouvoir voler la grande majorité des
Européens veulent l'Europe que j'ai
toujours prôné et c'est bien comme ça
dans une démocratie il faut aussi
permettre qu'il y ait à gauche et à
droite des gens qui est des opinions
différentes c'est normal faut les
écouter il faut discuter avec eux mais à
la fin du compte c'est la majorité et
celle-là elle se fait au centre c'est la
majorité qui décide est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas une forme d'angélisme aussi madame
Redding quand on sait que il y a encore
quelques semaines et on l'a vu encore ce
lundi en Allemagne il y a des
manifestations anti-musulmans il y a une
forme de rejet de l'autre au sein même
de l'Union vous l'aviez vous perçu quand
vous étiez à la vice-présidence de la
Commission européenne vis-à-vis des Roms
est-ce qu'il une forme d'angélisme parce
qu'on n'est pas là finalement juste dans
une espèce de séquence un petit peu
idyllique est-ce qu'on va pas revenir à
la réalité mais la réalité elle n'est
pas reluisante tout le temps bien sûr
qu'il y a des problèmes mais c'est pas
parce que il y a des problèmes qu'il
faut renverser toutes nos valeurs et
tous nos principes non bien au contraire
c'est de ces valeurs et de ses principes
qu'on va construire une politique pour
essayer d'intégrer ceux qui sont
intégrables et de dire aux autres que ça
ne va pas lorsque ils veulent combattre
ce qui est le fondement de nos sociétés
non il faut surtout pas de l'angélisme
mais ce qu'il ne faut surtout pas et
c'est ça que j'ai lu dans les dans les
masses qui se sont rassemblés il faut
surtout pas mettre par dessus bord nos
valeurs alors justement vous parlez de
ne pas mettre par dessus ben nos valeurs
il y a des valeurs qui sont celles de la
protection des individus et des libertés
individuelles Manuel Valls le Premier
ministre français donc à fait un
discours ce mardi devant l'Assemblée
nationale et il a interpellé les députés
européens je souhaiterais qu'on l'écoute
nous lancerons également la surveillance
des déplacements aériens des personnes
suspectes d'activités criminelles
c'est le système PNR j'appelle de
manière solennelle
ici dans cet enceinte le Parlement
européen apprendre enfin toute la mesure
de ces enjeux et de voter comme nous lui
demandons depuis deux ans avec
l'ensemble des gouvernements à adopter
ce dispositif qui est indispensable nous
ne pouvons plus perdre de temps
c'est passenger n'aime record donc c'est
un fichier d'enregistrement des
passagers vous en tant que député
conservatrice vous le voterez
ça dépend comment il est écrit alors
j'ai bien écouté Manuel Valls qui
paraît-il a fait un excellent
mais alors il a dit dans sa phrase il a
dit un fichier pour suivre les criminels
je suis tout à fait d'accord parce que
nous devons en tant que démocratie avoir
des instruments aux données aux forces
de l'ordre à la sécurité pour pouvoir
défendre notre société
des instruments forts c'est que je
regrette beaucoup que tous ces
instruments que nous avons au niveau
européen ils sont nombreux sont
malheureusement peu utilisés alors ça ne
sert à rien s'il y a des informations en
France qui ne passent pas au Luxembourg
qu'il y ait des informations en
Angleterre qui ne passent pas en
Allemagne la collaboration doit se faire
mieux mais il ne faut pas jeter le un
bébé avec l'eau du bain il faut faire
deux sortes à ce que on combatte les
terroristes à ce qu'on combatte les
criminels mais à ce qu'on enlève pas la
liberté et les droits des citoyens
lambda alors quand on a entendu par
exemple certains députés qui appelaient
un patriote à l'européenne vous n'êtes
pas du tout sur cette ligne là oh mon
Dieu on a vu ce qui s'est passé avec ce
patriothèque parce qu'il y a eu la
panique après le 9 11 aux États-Unis et
ils ont fait oui ils ont fait une
législation d'exception qui aurait dû
durer pendant quelques mois et bien elle
vient d'être renouvelée et je vous donne
un élément de cette législation qui va
tout vous expliquer sur base de cette
législation en 2013 il y a eu
perquisition perquisition sur ces 11000
perquisitions
51 avait très au terrorisme c'est à dire
tous les autres étaient contre les
libertés des citoyens non on ne veut pas
d'un patriothèque non on veut faire les
choses à l'Europe c'est à dire avoir
cette équilibre entre les droits et la
sécurité quand la sécurité doit agir
elle doit avoir les moyens elle ne peut
plus agir uniquement au plan national il
faut qu'il y ait ces réseaux très forts
qui couvrent toute l'Europe qui soit en
relation supplémentaire viennent comment
est-ce qu'on crée ça serment parce que
tout ça existe nous avons europopole
nous avons le fichier schinien tout ça
doit être renforcé mieux utilisé moi je
ne vois pas nécessairement la création
du nouvel instance j'avais à l'époque
proposé qu'on mette en place un système
de
services secrets européen mais plus pour
coordonner les autres que pour être un
service ce week-endarmerie mais la
coordination c'est ça qui nous manque
vraiment terriblement et je viens d'une
région frontalière je vois où sont
parfois les problèmes parce que les gens
ne vivent plus les frontières les gens
vivent dans une grande région ou
plusieurs états Luxembourg Belgique
Allemagne France et que les institutions
suivent c'est que les institutions tout
simplement sortent de leur carcan
national et aille dans un carcan
international et puis pour la France
j'ai beaucoup aimé les mesures qui ont
été annoncées par exemple pour dans les
prisons parce que les prisons ne peuvent
pas être une école du terrorisme aussi
le PNR que qui est demandé il n'aurait
rien servi pour les terroristes qui ont
sévi sur Paris parce que ils sont restés
à l'intérieur du accueilli donc vous
voyez il nous faut nous donner des
instruments supérieurs régionaux
supra-régionaux internationaux alors
dernière question rapidement madame
Redding il y a un autre problème qui est
celui de la radicalisation et on voit
qu'au niveau européen Europole annonçait
qu'il y avait environ 5000 djihadistes
présumés qui s'était rendu au Yémen en
Syrie en Irak qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces
gens-là une fois qu'ils reviennent mais
il y en a 30% de cela qui sont revenus
il faudra vraiment les contrôler il
faudra déjà faire de sorte à ce qu'ils
ne partent pas parce qui sont ces jeunes
qui partent et là aussi on doit se
réfléchir un peu ce sont souvent des
gens qui n'ont pas réussi dans la vie ce
sont des nobody comment on dit et à
travers des sans avenir des sans rien du
tout et à travers cette violence ils
deviennent quelqu'un alors là il y a eu
les familles les écoles la société qui
n'a peut-être pas très bien fait son
travail c'est un travail de longue
haleine c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut résoudre en 15 jours mais là aussi
j'espère bien que Charlie aura été le
point de départ du nouvel réflexion
qu'est-ce que nous faisons avec ces
jeunes ce sont surtout des hommes mais
ce sont de plus en plus aussi des femmes
pour que il n'est pas en vie de partir
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
pour évoquer cette question d'actualité
nous on continue sur un tout autre sujet
souvenez-vous il y a encore quelques
mois en nous vantait le modèle allemand
comme étant la dynamique économique pour
réussir alors nous avons voulu aller
voir en quoi cela consistait et
finalement c'est un modèle un petit peu
plus en trompe l'oeil c'est un reportage
de Cécile Sixou
ici c'est une des LAM usagers enlever
d'une machine qui nous a été envoyé et
qu'on aiguise
des larmes étincelantes c'est la
spécialité de Berne subinnes son
grand-père il y a plus de 100 ans à
créer cette entreprise de couteau
aujourd'hui cette PME familiale de
Cologne emploie près de 400 personnes et
exportent dans le monde entier
décisif dans la décision de nos clients
pour nos produits c'est la qualité de
l'innovation technologique nous essayons
toujours de trouver des meilleures
solutions pour répondre à de nouveaux
défis et pour le moment on y arrive très
bien
malgré la crise son entreprise est
restée en bonne santé Berne subinnes a
tout fait pour ne pas licencier
le nombre d'heures par semaine nous
avons eu recours au chômage partiel nous
avons supprimé l'intérim donc nous avons
vraiment utilisé tous ces instruments
outre Reims sont bien les PME qui sont
la colonne vertébrale de l'économie
en Allemagne et nous avons beaucoup de
pays me familial qui sont très orientés
vers l'exportation très présente à
l'international et très active dans la
recherche elles ont su être innovantes
et se sont établies sur leur marché et
continuent de se développer
flexibilité du travail main d'oeuvre bon
marché avec moins de 5% de chômeurs
l'Allemagne fait figure de locomotives
de l'Union européenne mais ce modèle
reste fragile
et là c'est la nouvelle
c'est brèches dans l'acier Hans les
connaît par cœur depuis deux ans il
colle Matt les fissures du pont de les
vertus Sun l'ouvrage n'a pas résisté au
passage quotidien de milliers de camions
depuis 2012 ils n'ont plus le droit de
l'emprunter
le problème principal c'est qu'entre les
années 60 et aujourd'hui le trafic a
énormément augmenté à l'époque nous
n'avions que 12000 camions et véhicules
sur le pont par jour aujourd'hui on en a
120 000 et là dedans il faut compter 20
000 camions et ça veut dire que toutes
les prévisions sont erronées du coup
l'usure est là
faute d'investissement et d'entretien
aujourd'hui 46% des ponts 20% des
autoroutes et 41% des routes nationales
sont dans un état critique
ce n'est pas seulement l'économie locale
mais l'économie au sens général qui
souffre beaucoup de cela
à un million d'euros par jour parce que
le pont est fermé pour les camions qui
doivent alors faire un détour et passer
par les ponts du centre-ville mais qui
sont eux aussi arrivés à la limite de
leur capacités
sont toujours le domaine qui a reçu le
moins d'argent en premier c'est toujours
naturellement l'éducation et le social
autre réalité de l'économie allemande la
pauvreté qui touche un sixième de la
population
bonjour
merci
donnez-moi quelques poivrons rouges
aussi
dans ce centre social sa retraite de
secrétaire ne lui permet pas de subvenir
à ses besoins
je touche 900 et quelques euros je paye
500 euros de loyer ensuite il y a les
assurances le téléphone l'électricité
donc à la fin il ne me reste plus grand
chose pour vivre
comme elle ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à venir s'approvisionner dans
cette association
existe nous avons remarqué que de plus
en plus de gens viennent des gens de
tout type on voit plus de familles mais
aussi plus de personnes seules plus de
personnes âgées
il y a des gens qui viennent ici qui
certes ont un travail mais dont le
salaire n'est pas suffisant pour
subvenir à leur propre besoin ou à ceux
de leur famille face à cette réalité le
gouvernement de coalition manga Merkel a
introduit le 1er janvier un SMIC horaire
à 8,50 €
en tout cas un enjeu de taille pour
l'Allemagne qui devra lutter pour rester
la première économie européenne
alors le modèle allemand est-il en train
de s'essouffler pour poser cette
question je reçois Évelyne Bart bonjour
vous êtes député allemande socialiste
démocrate on vous connaît bien dans
cette émission merci d'être avec nous
Dominique criquet bonjour vous êtes vous
député français membre du groupe libéral
et démocrates également quand vous voyez
Dominique criquet je m'adressais à vous
ce que ce reportage de Cécile Sixou
est-ce que vous vous dites encore que
l'Allemagne est un modèle économique à
suivre pour la France
avec ses avantages et ses inconvénients
la vue et la France avec ses avantages
et ses inconvénients j'ai à l'idéal ce
serait d'arriver à une solution qui soit
une synergie
défendre son outil économique en premier
alors que la France a fait le contraire
avec des choix qui ont à coup sur le
plan du chômage et du résultat
économique donc il faudrait arriver à
avoir en même temps des résultats
économiques et puis quelque chose qui
soit plus proche aussi du citoyen vous
êtes d'accord Evelyne entre le modèle
allemand et modèle français finalement
en effet ce serait la meilleure des
choses à faire parce que en Allemagne en
effet avec les infrastructures avec les
problèmes que nous avons avec la
pauvreté qui existent surtout pour les
femmes les femmes seules c'est un très
très grand problème qui a une relation
aussi avec le système d'imposition et
d'autres thèmes ont du mal à accéder à
l'emploi exactement et aussi le système
de l'école qui est toujours pas à plein
temps en général donc il donne des
problèmes particuliers en Allemagne
qu'il faut résoudre c'est clair mais en
même temps le système économique est un
système très positif qui aide à faire
avancer donc si on arrivait à faire une
bonne un bon équilibre entre les deux
systèmes allemands et français je pense
qu'on aurait une très bonne solution
alors là le problème c'est que on voit
bien que il y a un problème
d'infrastructure l'Allemagne a voté la
règle d'or et on l'a vu il y a encore
quelques jours c'est en orgueille
d'avoir un budget à l'équilibre de
nouveau sur cette année est-ce qu'on va
pas trop loin dans cette forme de
rigueur budgétaire quand on sait que
l'Allemagne par exemple n'investit que
2% de son PIB sur les infrastructures et
quand on voit que ça a un coût sur sur
les sur les infrastructures notamment
ses ponts qui ne peuvent plus être
empruntés Dominique criquet
trop élevé et que moi j'irai en France
d'un probablement poussé trop loin une
politique une politique de transfert
social au détriment de l'outil
économique et quand on par exemple on
exerce une politique de rigueur
budgétaire aussi importante que celle là
elle se fait au détriment des
investissements et les investissements
c'est la compétitivité économique de
demain donc l'excès lui en tout
l'équilibre est bon je pense que
l'Allemagne devrait relâcher sa
politique de rigueur budgétaire donc la
règle d'or pour vous n'est pas quelque
chose à suivre forcément la règle d'or
c'est d'arriver à un bon résultat moi je
vais vous dire c'est pas d'appliquer un
principe et donc en l'occurrence on voit
bien qu'actuellement il y a des
difficultés en Allemagne elles sont pas
du même ordre que des difficultés
françaises et c'est clair que le déficit
d'investissement aura un coup y compris
économique dans l'avenir parce que les
investissements maintenant c'est
l'activité de demain bien sûr Evelyne
Gobard justement sur cette question
d'investissement on a vu il y a quelques
temps donc au mois de décembre dernier
je voudrais qu'on passe mes Monsieur
Mélenchon qui est votre collègue ici au
sein de ce Parlement interpellé Madame
Merkel sur Framer accueil s'il vous
plaît enfin taisez-vous et laissez la
France faire quand vous voyez ce type de
rapport en fait entre les dirigeants
européens est-ce que vous vous dites
qu'on a encore une capacité de
travailler ensemble
obligé d'accepter aussi certaines
propositions des autres et dans la
société en Allemagne c'est en ce moment
c'est une des priorités que je trouve
fausse aussi de l'affaire avec cette
rigueur parce qu'en effet cela empêche
de
d'investir dans les infrastructures ce
qui est très important pour demain pour
le lendemain
cela empêche de faire quelques réformes
sociales qui seraient très nécessaire
aussi justement pour donner une réponse
à cette pauvreté surtout des personnes
âgées en Allemagne donc là il faudrait
faire quand même un revirement de
politique qui serait quand même assez
difficile
ma collègue madame c'est que les grandes
différences aussi entre l'Allemagne et
la France qui est pas seulement une
différence des politiques budgétaires
économiques mais que en Allemagne vous
pouvez avoir un gouvernement de
coalition ce qui n'est pas croyable en
ce qui est incroyable en France et ce
qui permet quand même de faire de
beaucoup avancer parce que vous trouvez
des politiques équilibrées et ça je
crois que c'est le plus gros avantage de
l'Allemagne ce n'est pas un avantage de
compétitivité économique c'est un
avantage de compétitivité politique il y
a une dimension comme comme pouvoir de
faire passer enfin un salaire minimum
il faut dire ça a duré 20 ans de lutte
pour les socialistes pour le faire
passer et on ne l'aurait pas eu si nous
ne l'avions pas fait cette coalition par
exemple donc ça c'est ça c'est clair à
l'image de cette coalition que du coup
qui existe en Allemagne et qui a
tendance à se mettre un petit peu en
place au niveau européen enfin tout du
moins certains l'appel de leurs vœux
comment se fait-il que cette capacité en
fait à travailler ensemble ne soit pas
du tout perçu de la part par exemple du
sud de l'Europe quand on voit les
problématiques en Grèce vis-à-vis de
l'Allemagne on a l'impression que
l'Allemagne avance fait cavalier seul
dans une forme de locomotive et que du
coup on abandonne tout le reste est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord madame je ne suis
pas tout à fait d'accord
même si je critique madame à quelle
régulièrement pour la manière dont elle
le fait parce qu'elle donne cette
impression elle ne sait pas vraiment
donner l'impression aux autres qu'elle
écoute les autres et ça c'est un très
gros problème mais moi j'aimerais bien
que l'Allemagne soit mieux perçu comme
non pas comme un cavalier seul mais
comme une entité à l'intérieur d'une
d'une société européenne et que nous
devons faire en sorte que nous ayons
cette solidarité de tout bord pour
donner des réponses positives aux
problèmes que nous avons aujourd'hui
Dominique Riquet sur cette question vous
quand vous voyez que l'Allemagne comme
ça est pointée du doigt est-ce que vous
vous dites que foncièrement il y a
peut-être aussi du vrai ou ou est-ce
qu'on va pas un petit peu trop loin sur
la manière dont on agite un petit peu le
chiffon rouge avec Madame Merkel qui
serait la la madame nine de l'Union
européenne je crois que c'est normal que
l'Allemagne elle soit au centre de la
cible c'est la première puissance
démographique économique en Europe oui
mais à l'horizon de 2050 elle ne se sera
peut-être plus donc
je vois la bannière la manière dont les
politiques réfléchissent souvent c'est
valorisant 2050
est-ce que je veux dire elle est dans
une situation éminente l'Allemagne et
donc comme tel tout le monde la regarde
la deuxième chose c'est que son modèle
économique fonctionne mieux à
discutablement que celui des autres j'ai
dit du modèle économique et donc elle a
tendance à dire et mon modèle marche
mieux que le vôtre
suivez donc mon exemple et c'est
d'autant plus visible que effectivement
c'est un pays qui est tout à fait
visible et qui est très grosse place sur
la scène européenne il y a d'autres pays
qui vont bien avec des modèles
différents alors l'Europe le Danemark va
pas mal par exemple
la Suède la Finlande ne vont pas si mal
la Finlande sort d'une très grosse crise
économique quand même
est-ce que je veux dire par là bon ils
sont quand même moins visibles ils sont
pas moins visibles parce que leur
politique sont meilleures au plus
mauvaise ou parce que leur politique
elles sont différentes sont moins
visibles parce que ils ont pas le volume
critique que peut avoir l'Allemagne en
Europe quand l'Allemagne est tendue
l'Europe s'en occupe
vous êtes vous êtes d'accord madame pas
bien sûr que on regarde plus l'Allemagne
parce que c'est un grand pays avec le
plus grand nombre de d'habitants et avec
une puissance économique quand même
assez forte mais cela signifie pas que
elle a le dernier mot sur la politique
européenne nous sommes 28 États membres
et c'est aussi la volonté politique des
autres qui doit se faire peut-être un
peu plus forte de temps en temps et de
bah oui bah oui donc finalement que dans
le concert des nations
socialistes en Europe donnent un peu
plus de voix élève un peu plus leur voix
par rapport à la politique conservatrice
parce que pour moi les politiques c'est
pas un pays ce sont des gouvernements
avec des majorités qui sont dans les
gouvernements qui qui décident de la
politique qui est faite et donc je pense
que là il y a un jeu qui doit se faire
un peu plus à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne et peut-être un peu moins de
de frissons d'un pays qui qui se disent
bon bah écoutez on fait ce qu'elle dit
puisque Madame Merkel le veut ainsi oui
bon bah écoutez de toute façon on verra
bien ce que ça donne d'ici quelques
temps merci en attendant à tous les deux
d'avoir été avec nous pour évoquer cette
question de essoufflement ou pas quoi
qu'il en soit des réformes sont
nécessaires nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à Bruxelles bonne
suite de programme sur les chaînes
parlementaires Ciao